morning mr corbin the leader of the
opposition
preparing for a major announcement on
brexit
after months of consultations and
confrontations jeremy corbyn is on his
way to change the party's position
on brexit but not before he has to run
the gauntlet
on the issue that dogs him wherever he
goes anti-semitism
a small protest had gathered outside
labour hq
demanding national executive members
meeting today reinstate
left winger chris williamson who was
suspended from labour
after saying the party was too
apologetic about anti-semitism
labor's nec deferred the decision
hours later three labour peers including
a former general secretary
lord treesman quit the party in the
lords putting those spending the day in
labour hq
on the back foot i've been in a meeting
for five hours so can you tell me what's
happened
i think that's extremely disappointing
obviously labour players are very valued
they obviously feel very strongly about
it
lord treesman who ran the labour machine
in the blair years described the
experience of life in the party now
as sickening lord dazi who was in gordon
brown's government
said that as a survivor of the armenian
genocide
he had zero tolerance to anti-semitism
and the decision hadn't been taken
lightly
labour hit back saying we completely
reject these false and offensive claims
the labour party at all levels is
implacably opposed to anti-semitism
and is determined to root out this
social cancer from our movement
and society anti-semitism has been the
biggest challenge for jeremy corbyn
alongside
brexit after months of facing both ways
leading to terrible results in the
european elections today the party
wanted to make clear that it was
starting to come off the fence
saying they will back a second
referendum and remain
in the face of any tory brexit
labor is a party which says we will take
no deal off the table and the people
will have a choice in the future
as to whether they remain in the
european union or they accept what would
be
very very damaging no deal exit in the
eu with the consequences
for food prices for medicine supplies
and industrial investment
labor has argued for the best part of 10
months ever since their party conference
last september
over whether to modify their brexit
policy but they are likely to have to
move again soon
jeremy corbyn's brexit decision gives
clarity over what will happen under a
tory government
but not in a labour one members will
have to wait until the eve of an
election to find out what happens then
sam coats sky news